[Música]
bienvenidos a reporteros el magazine de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de france 24
soy herminia fernández comenzamos
el cambio climático la sobreexplotación
para consumo humano y uso agrícola y la
falta de previsión para el futuro han
provocado que el río colorado que nace
en las montañas rocosas en eeuu ya no
llegue de manera natural a baja
california méxico y no se conecte con el
mar de cortez esto ha ocasionado una
alteración de ecosistema que afecta a la
flora y fauna de la zona y a las
poblaciones que habitan en el delta del
río en la parte mexicana en medio de una
sequía cada vez más grave una alianza de
organizaciones que involucra a las
comunidades locales ha impulsado que los
gobiernos de méxico y eeuu se
comprometan a destinar ciertas
cantidades de agua al año para uso
ambiental con el único propósito de
revivir el delta del río y restaurar los
ecosistemas dañados por más de 20 años
de falta de agua hoy nos acompaña
nuestro corresponsal en méxico mario
carbón el autor de este reportaje hola
mario gracias por acompañarnos
háblanos del problema de la sequía en la
zona noroeste de méxico y del este de
eeuu qué tan grave es la situación de
este río que beneficia a 40 millones de
personas
hola un gusto estar en el programa para
darnos una idea del problema de la
sequía en esta región el estado de baja
california
padece la célula sequía más severa en
los últimos 22 años de acuerdo con el
monitor de la comisión nacional del agua
30% del territorio está en sequía
extrema y 55% en sequía severa de hecho
la comisión nacional del agua ha
decretado el inicio de emergencia por
sequía en varios estados del país
particularmente del norte y por supuesto
en baja california el río colorado
además es considerado el más amenazado
de norteamérica este año y el lago mead
es donde está la presa hoover que
abastece a buena parte de la población
estadounidense y a méxico también está
en sus niveles más bajos desde
1937 de esa dimensión es la sequía y
bueno ha afectado como lo mencionas a
varias especies por ejemplo hoy día 10
especies de aves endémicas están en
peligro de extinción y 45 más tienen
algún grado de amenaza es por ello que
bueno es importante estos esfuerzos que
se están haciendo para revertir este
daño al medio ambiente en un ejemplo es
el sitio miguel alemán por ejemplo hace
seis años había sólo 23 especies de aves
y ahora con la reforestación y la
plantación de distintos árboles de
sauces mezquites álamos hay a 122
especies de aves gracias mario veamos la
historia
[Música]
en el valle de méxico y baja california
predomina un paisaje árido el delta del
río colorado que antes era un lugar
lleno de agua y vida hoy está seco
alfonso tambo es gobernador de los
cucapá una etnia que se asentó aquí hace
500 años tambo recuerda al río vivo y no
oculta la añoranza río me trae recuerdos
de nuestros antepasados y de mis padres
también iban a pescar y todo el río
colorado es algo es algo para mí me da
mucha tristeza cuando paso por el río y
lo veo seco porque porque dicen que
cuando el riego cuando cuando muere una
cosa mueren junto a la gente también
del lado de méxico la población de los
estados fronterizos de baja california y
sonora se han beneficiado del río por
siglos pero para los cucapá el valor del
colorado va más allá pues tiene que ver
incluso con su origen
qué es guapa gente que llega del río
guapa que le siguen
los que llegan pero como nosotros toda
la gente nos conoce como gente del río
colorado gente que lleva el río color
acampada
julie dimas es una ecologista y lleva
años trabajando en la restauración de
los ecosistemas del delta ha sido
testigo del daño en la zona provocado
por el cambio climático la
sobreexplotación para uso agrícola y la
contaminación
esta parte que vemos aquí en esta zona
era por donde pasado el río colorado
actualmente tenemos una zona muy
degradada del río en donde vemos
principalmente pinos al lado y no vemos
agua superficial además aquí alrededor
pues también se ha tenido el impacto de
que dejan mucha basura este río nace en
unas montañas a miles de kilómetros
arriba en colorado eeuu recorre 2.200
kilómetros hasta la frontera con mexico
ya su paso beneficia a más de 40
millones de personas de los dos países
una de las razones por las que se ha ido
secando es el calentamiento global las
altas temperaturas en colorado han
provocado que durante el año se formen
menos nieve se derrita más rápido y por
ello el río comienza a menguar desde el
inicio
jennifer pitt protectora del río
colorado ha investigado su caudal por
más de 20 años y advierte de su
situación crítica
está considerado como el más amenazado
en eeuu justo ahora
porque no solamente no está fluyendo
está en bares sí
sino que los embalses que son usados
para almacenar está agua para hacerla
accesible para todas estas millones de
personas
y todas estas millones de hectáreas de
tierra de cultivo se están quedando
vacíos muy rápidamente
jennifer fue impulsora de una alianza de
seis organizaciones sociales de méxico y
eeuu con un objetivo común convencer a
los gobiernos de los dos países de
trabajar en conjunto y devolver una
parte del agua que ya no existe en el
delta del río no flujos para uso
agrícola ni de consumo humano solo para
restaurar el ecosistema los llamados
flujos pulso el esfuerzo tuvo su primer
éxito en 2014
entonces
primero que nada trabajamos juntos
durante años para hacer posible lo que
ocurrió en 2014 tomo muchos años
alcanzar esos acuerdos diplomáticos pero
para 2014 eeuu y méxico acordaron poner
algo de agua en el delta del río
colorado
tú puedes amar
interculturalidad
si bien la crítica situación es más
evidente en la parte mexicana en eeuu se
nota también la escasez de agua en el
río
stephanie wells es oriunda de colorado
es piloto aviador y disfruta del río
desde la tierra y desde el aire nos
lleva en su avioneta a sobrevolar las
montañas y el río naciente su relación
con el colorado ha sido estrecha y está
consciente de otro problema la
sobreexplotación
la población está creciendo sin control
aquí en el lado oeste nuevas comunidades
emergiendo todo el tiempo y está
requieren agua y están tomando agua de
los acuíferos y los acuíferos se están
secando
de espíritu aventurero stephanie es
amante del río disfruta de hacer kayak y
la menta cuando no puede practicarlo
porque la corriente es muy baja pero más
le aflige que el río no llegue a méxico
me siento culpable porque durante muchas
décadas estados unidos ha tomado toda el
agua del río colorado antes de que
llegue
stemex
considerando que hace mucho tiempo el
río fluya hasta baja california
y creaba un área muy fértil para
cultivos y hoy es hoy una zona área un
desierto
la idea de esta alianza binacional para
revivir el delta es precisamente que ese
desierto del que habla stephanie recobre
un poco de vida y con los flujos pulsos
de agua que se liberan de las presas
entre mayo y septiembre se está
consiguiendo
de vuelta a méxico en baja california el
escenario es distinto esta zona es el
estuario donde solía juntarse el mar de
cortez con el río colorado en el final
de su trayecto desde las montañas
hoy eso ya no ocurre de manera natural
pero gracias a los flujos pulso cuando
hay luna llena y sube la marea se repite
la conexión
alejandro rosas es hidrólogo de sonora
institute y explica el beneficio de ello
disminuyó el flujo
al llegar la marea e interceptar el río
y genera también unas condiciones de
aguas salobres que también benefician a
especies que requieren de estas
condiciones para subsistir
una de esas especies es el cangrejo azul
cuando la marea se retrae de nuevo y
deja remanentes de agua que forman lodo
el cangrejo cava su guarida
entre los acuerdos binacionales
actualizados hoy en la minuta 323 se
establece la restauración de lo que hace
décadas fueran bosques ribereños uno de
ellos es el miguel alemán cerca de san
luís río colorado
qué es la gardenia es originaria de san
cuando era niña iba a divertirse con sus
primos en el agua hasta que desapareció
así como la vegetación alrededor por
ello decidió involucrarse como
voluntaria en este sitio de restauración
y pues ahora ya no hay río colorado tú
pasas y lo ves y está seco pero a la vez
no hay vida azul pero hay vida verde que
es esto lo que podemos ver pues o sea
puede que ya no haya agua pero esto eso
es lo que hemos estado haciendo pues
está reforestando para darle vida de
otra manera a fin de cuentas que isla
creció y con ella los álamos y mezquites
estudió leyes y hoy es abogada pero aún
se da tiempo para seguir plantando
árboles aquí
tal como se hizo con este sitio hay otro
proyecto en puerta julie dimas es la
encargada de convocar a la población del
valle a participar en este esfuerzo de
restauración y hablarles de los
beneficios del proyecto este va a ser un
futuro proyecto de restauración es un
hombre es jan y si aquí éste se cuenta
con la concesión de pronatura para
restaurar 140 hectáreas en en esta parte
del río la estrategia de destinar agua
exclusivamente para uso ambiental ha
rendido frutos no sólo para la
naturaleza también beneficia a los
agricultores de la zona
fabián tiene su rancho cerca del río y
explica cómo los flujos pulso favorecen
su siembra
gracias a los flujos
de aquí de agua del río colorado y el
calor ya no es tan tan intenso aquí todo
lo que es a quien pegado ha recordado y
ya eso nos ayuda a que nuestros cultivos
tengan un mejor mejor crecimiento la
verdad es que estamos aquí pegados al
río colorado nos damos nos damos cuenta
de la realidad
luego de aquella primera descarga de
2014 el ejercicio se retomó en 2021 y
ahora en 2022 pero a diferencia de la
primera vez que se vertió agua
directamente sobre las zonas áridas en
esta ocasión se conduce desde la presa
morelos que es una presa derivadora ya
en la parte mexicana por los canales de
riego hasta los sitios de restauración
para un mejor aprovechamiento de los
flujos además al haber más agua en el
río los agricultores pueden diversificar
su actividad de granja como lo hace
fabián álvarez nos podemos dedicar a la
agricultura podemos poner un estanque de
camarón o de tilapia o bagre
no sólo los peces nadan ahora en estas
aguas también hay una gran variedad de
aves y familias de castores y otros
animales
carlos niebla es un joven biólogo que
monitorea la fauna en el sitio de
restauración laguna grande en mexica le
explica algunos beneficios para los
animales
los flujos de agua federal han promovido
que los meandros dentro del río colorado
se conecten haciendo que las poblaciones
de castores puedan expandir más su
hábitat esto también promueve la
competencia entre ellos haciendo que la
salud de la especie como tal sea mayor
cada vez
más allá de los campos agrícolas y las
zonas de restauración san luís río
colorado es una ciudad seca y desolada
sus habitantes añoran el río
karina y manuel no son ambientalistas
son escritores pero desde su trinchera
contribuyen a los esfuerzos por revivir
el colorado karina es odontóloga maestra
de música y poetisa pero sobre todo es
sanluisina de corazón y por ello
escribió un poema para el río colorado
ese llano arenas hermosas colorido
terrestre no se extingue la hermosura
por tu ausencia
sobre la antes antología yo creo que es
la oportunidad de hacer un tipo de
protesta nuestro sobre lo que ha
sucedido con el río colorado y pues a mí
me surgen un poco las letras y creo que
es la oportunidad de poder poder es de
plasmar lo que mi sentimiento hacia esa
tristeza que tenemos manuel es pintor
escritor y editor fue idea suya lanzar
una invitación a escribir poemas sobre
el río colorado y recibió 20 textos que
él editó
y también el nivel literario en el en el
nivel artístico podamos seguir
trabajando para generar más conciencia a
nivel mundial de que necesitamos que el
río vuelva a ser lo que antes fue
hay otros ciudadanos al vecinos
comprometidos con la idea de rescatar el
río desde su ámbito es el caso de nancy
saldaña una arquitecta que diseñó un
proyecto de parque lineal cerca de la
valla fronteriza hay donde alguna vez
corría el colorado y donde en 2014 se
liberó el agua que tanto jubiló dio a
los habitantes como lo recuerda su hijo
ulises
también ya cuando llegó al agua
no conocía ningún niño de los que
estaban ahí
y nosotros vamos a jugar todos porque
estábamos muy emocionados de que se haya
cumplido y algo que nunca habíamos visto
a 40 minutos en carretera de san luís
río colorado en yuma arizona se
encuentra el get away park un espacio
destinado a la recreación de los
habitantes ahí donde aún fluye de manera
natural el río colorado y la gente acude
a bañarse en sus aguas y convivir
de ahí tomó un ansia y su inspiración
para hacer un proyecto para san luís río
colorado
en el parque lineal nosotros estamos
diseñando un espacio con el deseo de
tener contacto con el agua que haya por
temporadas agua natural del río colorado
y donde podamos introducirnos y bañarnos
en esta en esta área de la de la playa
por ahora lo más cercano a un sitio de
esparcimiento con agua del río colorado
en la parte mexicana es el paraje
conocido como vado carranza en el valle
de mexicali en 2021 y ahora en 2022 las
descargas de agua para uso ambiental han
inundado esta árida zona permitiendo a
la población reencontrarse con el río al
menos por unos meses para josé manuel
habitante de mexicalli desde hace 30
años el vado carranza ha sido una grata
sorpresa y aún es una maravilla es una
maravilla porque tiene la oportunidad de
disfrutar pues sobre todo para
refrescarte este calor tremendo que es
un musical y yo no me había topado con
un lugar así no no la verdad que no hay
albercas pero no hay lugares así al aire
libre en el cual puedes disfrutar el
tiempo que quieras y sobre todo fíjate
que el agua está bien limpia
los esfuerzos binacionales tanto de
gobiernos como de organizaciones y de
ciudadanos en particular no revertirán
de un día para otro el grave daño que se
ha hecho a este recurso natural del
planeta pero son un buen comienzo y han
logrado despertar conciencia entre los
habitantes de ambos lados de la frontera
hasta aquí reporteros de la semana
recuerda que para sintonizar esta y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
hasta la próxima
[Música]